>> ♪>>ean:AR 2F SA CART'S
CLIVE REPTING OHE
TANGS IIDE TEXA D TR
UG REHOUSE.
TA A LO.
THE DGSHAT ARE SEIZE
VE BEENROUG TO THIS
CATI.
WHERE WE HE OUR CME LAB
IENTISTSO AUGALYS.
TALKG AUTARIO DGS --
RIJUA, CAINEND ANYL.
OV,000 PNDSF DIFRENT
>> TSACITY ONE?T TS
HOW CHOU TTE WOR ON
TH STRE?
10FILLI DOLLS.
SOM OF E BGEST ISSUE
>>OU A RIG ON POINT.H'S ACRISF L
AEEIN COUERFE PIL
NUFAURED BYRUG
TH MANACTU THAT DGND
MOVE ITCRSNTO OSTES.
TH'S WHATEREEEING WI
AMICANBEUSENDIVUALS DON KNO
ATIND OF DRUHEY AINSTIN>> TALD
CHILEN HAV TAKEN A LL AAPAY.
EY WEOT KWNRUG UCTS
ADDIS.THR KIDSID NSERUGS
RELARL
YBET S AE TISE ATH ED.
YOUNG AALL MESNOLLE
Y THIHIS AAIN
MEDITIONRTIMUTEO KEEP
EMAY
ESE CNTFEITILLS ARE
KILLIN THOANDS OAMERICS.
IT'S ALL FLING BAC IO T
THEEDER GERNMT IS N
TANG ANYACTION.
THAT WHY WE TAKECTIO TO
FEGUD R TEXANS D T
ST OF E COUN
>> SeaARA RTOINSS
NOW.
YEARS AGO AUGAREHSE
HA BEE DOW TO THE BORR
LIKEOUAVE BEENANY MES.
MES.WH I SAW THI WAHOUSE,F
U CA GETHROUGH T SNCH
OFIT, IT'LOOR TO I CLING
DRUGS.
E DFENCE WITH FEANYL IF
U HAVE TWO GINS OF SALT
>>RREC WL KL A 250PODMA
AT'SHAT THE L ENFORCENTOFCIAL I
THE UNTR AND TSEHA
RKEDN THE CMEABS WER
TRYI TOENDUT THE WARNG.
THATWAING.SOENNG OUT
CHILEN OVER 93,0 ORDOSES
DEATH LAS YE.
CORDGO THORON I
OHIO THO NBERSRE EEEDED
THEY ARE CONCERNE
INAA ANDHE MEXAN CTELSREIN T MA.
TH AREHERIRY
STRITOF FENTANYN TH
UNIT STAT.
THE PLS LOO INTICALO TH
PILLSESIBED LIK A CTOR
U WOU S FENNYLHAT
PRESCRIB.IKHEILLS
THIS IS WHA PENTS ANDAW ENRCEMT
PEOP TO KNOWCROSTHE
TALK TOOUR CHDREN
LK TO YR FRIEND
LK T YR FALY
LET THENOF YAKE APILL
AT IS N PRCRED B YR
CTOR Y A PYING RSIAN
ULET WH YR LIFE.
EY ARE POIN AND PEOE ARE
>>ean:T'SHAPPENG.
'S THE NUMBE1 KILRF
PEOPLE8O 3 I THIOUNT
GHTNO
IT ATRAGEDY